les nigérians l'exigé depuis plusieurs
jours ils ont finalement obtenu la
suppression de cette brigade controversé
accusé d'extorsion d'arrestations
illégales et même de meurtre sa
dissolution a été annoncée plus d'une
semaine après le début de la
contestation la brigade spéciale de
lutte contre les vols de la police
nigériane également connu sous le nom de
sar ce est dissoute dans toutes les
formations les 36 commandement de police
d état et le territoire de la capitale
fédérale où elles existent actuellement
la police a toutefois assuré que les
officiers de la sarce seraient
redéployés dans d'autres brigades
anticriminalité et qu'une unité spéciale
de surveillance des crimes sera mise en
place
mais du côté de la population la
suppression de cette brigade est
accueillie avec soulagement
ce qu'il s'est passé c'est révélateur du
fait que les nigérians peuvent
réellement s'exprimer
le fait est que les nigérians peuvent se
rassembler pour une cause et faire des
choses les gens savent que nous avons
une voix c'est une décision très
importante
c'est un développement très bienvenu
parce que les gens se sont plaints
il faut s'en débarrasser il faut s'en
débarrasser
la mobilisation des nigérians a été
porté par plusieurs célébrités du pays
un rassemblement a même eu lieu à
londres ce dimanche
à cette occasion le chanteur nigérian
whisky d'annoncer la nouvelle aux
manifestants sur place
[Applaudissements]